the queen has spoken and it's kind of
popped up
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we are back with a
heavily requested harper's bizarre what
i in a day review
on the domestic queen herself martha
stewart
so first let me talk about my sponsor
bill barr you guys now know that i've
been sampling these bars for a few
months now
and i'm still totally loving them and
thanks to your comments i
also learned about the joys of eating
these slightly melted in the microwave
so good i mean throw a little ice cream
on top oh my gosh
yes but i don't honestly eat a whole lot
of protein or energy bars
usually because i just don't love the
texture or flavor
but i do think that protein bars can be
a really convenient source of protein
for busy days
and if they taste like a marshmallowy
nugget chocolate bar you can sign me up
so
today's flavor salted caramel
i'm a salted caramel freak
um come on
well that is good also a quick reminder
about the
zero guilt label on the package
i mean you know i'm gonna say right
unless you stole it from a baby
or a breastfeeding mama all food is
zero guilt but anyways nutrition wise
each bar has 17 grams of protein
so they are ideal if you want to like
add it to a snack or a meal to really
bump up the satiety factor and since
they are lower in sugar
if i were to have this as a post-workout
snack i would always try to pair it with
maybe some fruit
or piece of toast or oatmeal to balance
the protein
with carbs and some natural sugars so if
you want to give these bars a try
use my promo code and check out the link
below for 20
off of your order also you can pause the
screen or look at the description below
to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered
eating and of course don't forget to
subscribe to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out
all right martha gave it to me it's very
difficult for me to stay in bed
later than say 6 15. i wake up really
early
way earlier than that i've already read
the newspaper the new york times covered
a cover
done the crossword puzzle tried to do
word play oh girl i feel seen
i like to think i relate to martha
because
clearly both of us have forgotten what
it's like
to chill the [ __ ] out then i go into the
kitchen
for my green juice uh scratch that
on the relatability factor this is where
we diverge my green juice is very
special to me i think it's
really the secret of good skin i think
it's the secret of good healthy hair
so the green juice cucumbers parsley
mint if i have it a little piece of
ginger which i do not grow
i had like a half of an orange including
the skin okay
so first of all the woman is 79
so her hair is truly hair goals for me
right now at 33. the woman looks great
second it's somewhat true that eating an
abundance of fruits and vegetables which
are rich in vitamin c
which can help support collagen
production may help support
healthy skin and hair but while getting
more antioxidants in your diet
instantly make your hair more beautiful
probably not as much
as good jeans would especially if you're
not actually
deficient but sure like a general
healthy diet
can help support strong healthy hair and
skin
true the vegetables primarily come from
my vegetable greenhouse
or my garden all year round i'm growing
my own vegetables because i want
organic i want clean i want tasty
and i want healthy what i don't love is
martha's
suggestion that she grows her own
vegetables to make sure that they're
you know clean and healthy that to me
feels a little exclusive and
also kind of misinformed all vegetables
are good vegetables to me
they don't need to be talked too sweetly
or grown in organic fertilizer from
martha stewart's personal
compost in fact they don't need to be
organic
at all i've talked about organics before
in my video on sorel amore right here so
i'm not going to go into too much detail
but i will just say that there is
no strong evidence that organic produce
is significantly more nutritious
than conventional so for me if your
budget comes down to choosing
more conventional produce or less
organic produce
i will always recommend more of whatever
is more economical to you
i generally run outside and get in my
polaris
and i drive around the property i also
check on my animals i check
on the horses i check on the donkeys i
have five of
sicilian donkeys they're really cute and
they're very lively
i check on the 20 peacocks i check on
the 34
homing pigeons and i check on the geese
that come from
four different countries oh my god
only martha would have 25
peacocks and 17 international geese
because american geese are just not
bougie enough for this queen
okay so i am kind of jealous about the
donkeys though because those do sound
like they would be pretty cool
in the morning i'm making waffles i go
back
to my kitchen and i treat myself to
the most delicious cappuccino made on my
trusted san marco
two cup cappuccino machine i feel like
martha is trolling us with all these
like
luxury brand name dropping i just think
it's hilarious that she clearly has
no interest in even seeming somewhat
relatable
it's sort of the hub of the kitchen and
i just found really good organic milk
i mean in her head she's probably like
cackling and being like
bow down [ __ ] i'm martha i'm stuart
you peasants cannot even like dream
about
a day in my over-the-top foodie palace
and it's true we can't but anyways i
feel like martha stewart and i started
off
this day on the same page with the type
a
can't sleep won't sleep neuroticism
situation
but i've realized that the big
difference
is that martha is making all of us feel
like
lazy while she gets up to frolic in her
foodie themed adult disneyland
meanwhile meanwhile i'm up early because
i've got a screaming child
on my boob and another one having a
tantrum because
i told him that i wouldn't microwave his
smoothie that morning
yeah so same same but different
i am not a snacker i try very hard to
keep nothing in the house that
will entice me as a snack that said
people are always bringing me delicious
pastries from new york and breads
from here and there but i really like to
keep
that away from me so this is feeling a
little
like the kelly ripa interview i mean
these are definitely
type a women and i too identify with
that so
i get it my sense from this interview
thus far
is that martha has no shortage of access
to quality food in her home but when she
says she's not a snacker
and doesn't keep snacks in the house or
anything that would entice her
i think she means that she doesn't buy
or eat
lower quality processed food snacks
so unlike my man little yachty
we're talking probably no chips no candy
bars no cheap crackers or
other packaged foods and that's cool and
totally fine
but since we haven't really seen much of
a meal yet
just like a fancy cappuccino and a low
calorie green juice
i definitely think there's room for a
snack or
for a more substantial breakfast here
something ideally
with some protein and fat to carry her
to lunch
so that could be some whole foods too
like yogurt and fruit cheese and whole
grain crackers
trail mix or some nut butter on toast
but
let's take a look at what our lunch
looks like i tried very very hard to eat
a very light lunch maybe a tuna fish
salad
i make a really good tuna fish salad
italian tuna of course packed in olive
oil
celery crispy apple maybe a half of a
shallot lots and lots of lemon juice and
a little bit
of mayonnaise of course martha will find
a way to turn the
most humblest of lunch options tuna
salad
into a posh highbrow dish
first of all you don't need fancy
italian tuna in olive oil to make a
healthy tuna salad
i looked up the bottle that they
photographed in this video which may or
may not be what martha actually eats
but it cost almost 10 times what i pay
for tuna
at walmart i'm sure it's delicious and
obviously
she can afford the best so martha girl
you go and buy the best
but generally speaking tuna is one of
the most
economic protein options that you can
buy so i'm just saying that you don't
need to live on a
20 acre mansion to have tuna salad
for lunch i will just flag that if
you're eating a lot of canned tuna
you may want to opt for the light
variety which is
lower in mercury than the more popular
albacore variety
so albacore is still lower in mercury
than
fresh tuna steaks but most authorities
recommend limiting your consumption to
one to two cans of albacore per week
also it's worth noting that some
light tuna labeled as tono or gourmet
may actually be made with larger
skipjack varieties
which may have comparable amounts of
mercury to albacore
in other words your bargain bin tuna may
actually be healthier than martha's
gourmet version
if limiting heavy metal consumption is a
priority for you
just saying but mercury's side i'm sure
if martha is making a tuna salad
then it's a damn good tuna salad and i
love that we've got our protein
we've got some healthy fats in the olive
oil plus a little produce in the mix
but again with so little fuel in her
morning
i was definitely expecting a more
substantial
lunch at least a few slices of bread in
there to make a sandwich
would help to bulk this up but anyways
let's see what dinner looks like
last saturday i made a delicious dinner
i had gone to the store
and i bought a plump organic dartanian
chicken
and i bought a rack of lamb fresh string
beans
i went to my greenhouse and i picked all
kinds of beautiful frisee
and soft buttercrunch lettuces i've
recently learned how to roast the
chicken
sort of like nomad style or 11 madison
park style
in case you're not in the loop on the
most
exclusive roast chicken dinners
martha is referencing new york city's
celebrated three michelin star
restaurant
11 madison park which was awarded the
world's
best restaurant in 2017. getting a
reservation
is literally an olympic sport and the
meal with wine pairings will cost you
a modest eleven hundred dollars per
person
so yeah my guess is that most people
watching this little interview
won't know much about this magical roast
chicken
technique but i'm a foodie so now i'm
intrigued
martha tell me more then the day of
cooking
um you if you have some black truffles
lying around
i'm sorry if you just have some
black truffles lying around this is like
that popular instagram meme
top point zero zero zero zero zero one
percent style
tell me you're a multi-millionaire
without saying
you're a multi-millionaire take a whole
stick
of unsalted butter the best butter like
plugra
or kerry gold and you slather it all
over the skin of the chicken okay so i
hear a lot of influencers talk about
only using
kerry gold or a similar luxury butter
brand
but does it actually make a difference
to your health
so i will say in terms of flavor that's
obviously subjective
but personally yeah i can taste the
difference
especially if i'm using it on something
really neutral like bread
where the flavor of the butter can
really shine so i do personally
get the appeal when it comes to taste
kerrygold
also gets its golden yellow hue because
the cows are grass-fed instead of corn
fed
which does give it slightly higher
levels of beta-carotene
conjugated linoleic acid and omega-3
fats
having said that i wouldn't personally
bank on butter
to get my omega-3 fats because you'd
have to eat a lot of butter
to get any kind of measurable benefit
and butter is kind of one of those
things that we
usually recommend consuming in
moderation
so if you like the flavor of grass-fed
butter
and you're consuming it as like a luxury
item
not so much as a heavily used cooking
oil then
by all means like it might be worth the
splurge to you
but i would personally choose it mainly
for the flavor and
using it where the flavor actually
matters and
not so much for any of its added health
benefits
but anyway back to the meal a good roast
chicken or lamb dinner with spring
veggies
always sounds divine and obviously
inherently very nutrient dense
but i'm getting the sense that martha
tends to eat
pretty low carb i mean we've got no
carbs at breakfast no carbs at lunch
not a lot of carbs at dinner which again
totally cool
if it works for her but i'm just
flagging to point out
that i think there's definitely room
here for
like a sweet potato or a slice of bread
i really like to open an appropriate
bottle or two
or three of wine i really like to drink
just a small vodka cocktail i never
drink alone
but when friends come over having a nice
vodka on the rocks
with a slice of orange from my own
greenhouse and the vodka has to be
really good it has to be like the best
belvedere vodka
nothing but top shelf for our girl
martha
in my refrigerator good parmesan cheeses
cream cheese
really good organic milk butter and i
have fresh eggs from the chickens
for all the money that martha saves
avoiding snack foods in her house
i am sure she more than makes up for it
with her organic
dairy budget there's definitely a
growing interest in organic dairy
making up about fifteen percent of all
organic food sales
and almost five percent of all dairy
sales
so why are people shelling out more cash
for organic
milk well in short most of the interest
in organic dairy that i've seen from
consumers
is related to pesticides antibiotics and
growth hormones so let's do a wii
overview to set the record straight it
is true that all organic dairy
must be produced without any gmos
synthetic pesticides fertilizers and
herbicides
and that recombinant bovine growth
hormone is
not allowed in organic dairy production
but
a lot of conventional milk today also
isn't using growth hormones in their law
anymore
since this has become such a heavily
requested consumer selling point
so growth hormones in dairy have been
declining in the general dairy supply
for
many years now great as for antibiotics
both organic and conventional cows can
be treated with antibiotics
but they'll be milked and the milk will
be discarded
the only difference is that an organic
cow will be
permanently removed from the milking
herd and the conventional one will be
put back into rotation
once the antibiotics have completely
cleared her system
so again no antibiotics in milk
the other myth is that all organic cows
are 100 grass-fed
which as we already mentioned would
suggest that the milk is higher in
omega-3s
and it can be about 50 percent more than
conventional which
i think is pretty significant but it's
worth noting that organic grain
corn and soybeans are also allowed as
part of organic jurisdiction
so if you want 100 grass-fed milk
that's something specific that you're
going to have to source i bake
two big sally lun popka bread a slice of
that is light and fluffy
it's delicious lightly toasted and it
makes
the best the best breakfast bread
pudding
oh my gosh babka bread pudding
yes i mean if this is how martha wants
to eat her carbs
i can't fault her on that now i expect
she doesn't eat vodka bread pudding
every day on the regular but i would say
based on
the rest of her day she totally could if
it brought her joy
and on that note what can we say about
martha stewart's diet well it's
certainly healthy there's
no doubt that operating a legitimate
farm
has its perks when it comes to a
nutritious diet
she's got a bounty of beautiful fresh
local fruit
veggies and eggs which don't have to
undergo
long travel periods and that generally
will mean that they're
able to be consumed at peak nutrient
levels
she also has money to buy really high
quality artisan cheeses
and butter and milk and a casually snack
on black truffles instead of drugstore
chocolate truffles and she drinks top
shelf liquor with a twist of orange from
her
orangery not sugary coolers from the
corner store bodega
i mean i'm confident that the quality of
ingredients
going into this woman's body is probably
pretty top notch
but it just doesn't seem like a lot
i know she's almost 80 so her nutrition
needs are certainly
not as robust as a lot of the
influencers that you see me review here
but still your average woman over 50
living a somewhat active lifestyle
needs at least 1800 calories a day and
martha seems
pretty involved in wrangling her donkeys
and geese every day
so my guess is that she could definitely
use more carbs so let's switch gears and
offer a few gentle nutrition tips based
on this interview
first of all we could definitely try to
beef up our breakfast with a source of
carbs
protein and fat and also of course to
add
more carbs throughout the day this could
mean maybe some oatmeal and boiled eggs
with her green juice at breakfast
a few slices of bread on her tuna salad
at lunch
and maybe a couple roast potatoes or
sweet potatoes at dinner
simple and still very in line with her
local luxury brand moving on to
martha's relationship with food
obviously given the format of this video
i've had to make
a lot of super unscientific
unsubstantiated assumptions here
but i do think it's safe to say that the
woman is a bit of a control freak
i mean she's martha stewart of course
she's type a the woman is famous for
teaching people how to
effortlessly match a robin's egg blue
table runner
with your stationary organizer bins to
create a
seamless vista when you look across the
room
while you're serving homemade croissants
at brunch
she's not exactly living the messy
disheveled i showered once this week
reality
of so many working families right now so
as a result it isn't really surprising
to me that her day feels
pretty regimented and a little
disconnected from reality
there's definitely a set of unspoken
rules that she probably lives by
in general and it wouldn't be surprising
to me if that
leaks into her food choices as well and
that's totally cool
but i did hear some moralizing talk
around food in her interview
as she talked about organic homegrown
food as being clean
or more healthy and that she didn't keep
snacks
or other foods that would entice her
around in the house
that alone tells me that martha likely
has some strong opinions
on what is acceptable and unacceptable
when it comes to what to eat
a lot of the time these beliefs are
rooted in status class and privilege
in addition to being influenced by
popular wellness culture
so while i think that martha's diet is
generally quite beautiful and healthy
and the woman's physical and mental
stamina seems like a pretty good
testament of that it's also important to
note that
being in an economic position to
casually throw truffles onto your roast
chicken
or leisurely enjoy your 20-acre farm
may also play a significant role what
i'm saying is kind of
obvious but let's not compare ourselves
to martha stewart
or her diet even if you manage to
emulate her diet to a tea
her own socioeconomic status and life
opportunities
may likely result in a completely
different outcome
for health and on that note i just want
to say that
i love martha with all of my heart i
mean
her unapologetic you can't touch me
luxury brand is
deeply entertaining to me not relatable
in
any way but entertaining no doubt
honestly i could listen to the woman
talk about her homing pigeons
all day but thankfully i have the
critical thinking skills
and the sense of self to know that i
don't need that life to be happy either
so hopefully this video inspired a
similar critical thinking process for
you
a big thank you again to biltbar for
sponsoring this video if you liked it be
sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with who you'd like to see me review
next
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye